[Music]
this is SE c-110
we're gonna talk about how to discover
and protect sensitive data virtually
anywhere and thank you for joining us
today and let's just go ahead and get
started my name is Scott Ellis I'm a
product manager on our cloud security
and privacy team and what we're gonna
cover today is we're gonna give a quick
intro about protecting sensitive data
kind of what sensitive data is and just
some basic principles around protecting
it and then we're gonna get a little bit
of an overview of some tools that we're
going to use and then go into a scenario
and some live demos of actually kind of
solving some scenarios and applying our
tools to solve these problems then we're
gonna show you some of these demos and
kind of give you an overview and then we
also have some some samples and how-to
guides and stuff we'll give you a link
to for you to run this yourselves so to
get started when we talk about sensitive
data you know the security and privacy
of the sensitive sensitive data is a top
priority we take it very seriously at
Google and at Google cloud but we hear
it from our customers as well that it's
just a big concern knowing what it is
knowing where it is and managing it
properly and when we think about
protecting sensitive data just to kind
of highlight like the main goals that
you're looking for here is really
fundamentally using that data properly
you might refer to this as something
like lease privilege or need to know
which is how do I get this the minimum
amount of data that I need to do a
particular business process and also is
this a good business process is this
something I should be doing just making
sure you're kind of managing that data
and that's a good policy to have but the
second goal is really how do you be
accountable for that in other words you
have a policy how do I actually
demonstrate that the company's following
this policy we have checks and balances
we have tools in place we have reports
and monitoring we can generate to show
that we're accountable and again
demonstrate that property use and maybe
it's monitoring
maybe it's auditing and then also plans
in place to kind of remediating
and as you're doing that you want to
maintain that strong governance as your
business grows as your data grows and do
that with some minimal hindrance to your
employees to your development to your
business and your service to users so
those are kind of the primary goals in
some kind of underlying ways we want to
do it
when we think about ensuring this kind
of data protection or kind of governance
across data you have to think about the
whole data lifecycle
just at a high level that's really where
you're collecting data where you're
storing it we're processing this data
maybe you're using it for analytics or
sharing it with other people
and I'm gonna highlight one thing here
is you also want to address areas where
you might be inadvertently collecting
sensitive data something where you don't
expect it to be there but it still shows
up and that's something that's so you
have to look out for and we're gonna
highlight an example of that in our in
our demos and what we're gonna do is
we're gonna walk through a scenario so
imagine you're a company you manage a
lot of customer orders you've got
customer transactions and customer
support that you provide and your goal
is you want to build some sort of new
analytics or some machine learning model
to provide really good customer support
and we're gonna kind of walk through a
scenario of this company and we want to
kind of accomplish three main things
today so first is can I do a scan to
discover an audit kind of where my
sensitive data is in in our cloud
project then we're gonna look at how we
can apply some real-time redaction to do
to kind of remediates some unexpected
sensitive data that we've collected and
lastly we're gonna kind of deep dive and
look at D identification and risk
analysis really looking at data and
preparing it to share with an internal
team or an external team who might be
doing some analytics or as a partner
providing some additional insights to
your data we're to kind of walk through
these scenarios and show this kind of an
action but before we do that we want to
do is cover some of the tools that we're
going to talk about today so one of the
primary tools we're going to talk about
is the cloud data loss prevention or DLP
API that's one of the primary things
we're going to cover we'll go in a
little bit more depth but other tools
that we're going to mention some of you
may be familiar with some of you may not
be so it's kind of good a quick overview
here so we're gonna talk a little about
a little bit about Google Cloud Storage
sometimes called GCS which is a sorry
about that
oh you switch back to the slides talking
about Google cloud storage which is kind
of an enterprise object storage we're
talking about bigquery which is a fully
managed data warehouse and kind of
analytics system for large you know any
scale really but small to large scale
kind of under workflow management we're
going to talk about it
we'll call data flow which is a kind of
stream and batch processing workflow
that you can do a lot of transformations
or ETL type workloads on and we're going
to use a visualization tool called cloud
data studio so all of these tools are
available for you we're gonna just
reference them and so we just want to
give a quick overview but let's dive a
little bit deeper on cloud data loss
prevention so this is a suite of tools
that really helps you control and take
charge of your data we've built it for
cloud and kind of hybrid use cases it's
primarily offered through G suite as
well as our cloud platform we're not
going to cover a lot of the G suite
stuff today but this is really something
that is a tool to help protect and
discover and protect sensitive data in
in applications like Gmail and drive
we're gonna focus a little bit more in
the API today which really allows you to
protect sensitive data on Google cloud
platform and because it has some
streaming message you can really apply
it to data anywhere and we're going to
show a couple examples of that so the
main capabilities of our API we've kind
of broke it down into three three groups
here the first one is really discovery
and classification of data the second
one is to perform different types of
what we call D identification transforms
this is things like simple redaction
masking and more advanced things like
format preserving encryption
tokenization suit automation and things
like that and and the third up is a what
we call reai identification risk
analysis this is some additional tools
to look at your data and do some
statistical analysis of it to understand
if it has additional risk of
re-identification and we're going to
cover some of the tools like Canon in
MIDI and El diversity and some other
other things that it does today we're
going to focus on Canon MIDI and share
an example of how to apply that so when
you talk about discovery and
classification what we mean is
effectively looking at data that you
don't know what's in there
applying some of our built-in
classifiers we have 9 over 90 of them
today and this includes things like
personally identifiable information
PII like names location dates we have
global types that kind of apply anywhere
credit card numbers as well as some
country specific identifiers you can
also define your own so this again is
maybe you have an internal customer ID
a patient medical record number
something that's not really well defined
in the industry you can define that
yourself using custom dictionary custom
pattern based things like regex and
we've also enhanced that with some
custom detection rules that allow you to
apply some kind of boosting or looking
at the context around the finding but
again the whole main purpose here is
looking at data you don't know what's in
there and trying to come out with kind
of discovering and classifying sensitive
bits that are there when we talk about D
identification and we have a little
animation showing some examples here
we're really talking about kind of easy
to use transformations handling both
structured and unstructured data what
we're showing in this animation is we've
got three columns of data really or four
columns of data three of which are
structured
if you imagine just sort of the first
second and third column has an
identifier has a job title has a phone
number and we're applying some different
techniques to mask those on the job
title we're doing a kind of
generalization and then the last one
it's a little bit of a different column
it's a comment field we can't really
apply a transformation to that whole
column other than maybe redaction so
what we really have to do there is apply
a combination of that discovery and
classification to look for the things we
care about and then apply some sort of
transformation so if you see here with
the email address or the phone number
we're actually hunting inside the
comment field and then applying a
transformation there and we also can do
this on text files again kind of a blob
of text if you will or like a tabular
structure as well as on images when we
talk about Rio Dental patient is that
kind of third category I'll just show an
example here that might kind of explain
it and then we're gonna go in a little
bit more in depth and kind of show it in
use imagine you had this table where
you've stripped out user IDs stripped
out what's commonly known kind of types
of PII but you're left with something
like job title and just some metric that
you want to protect you don't want
people to know you know who that metrics
associated with effectively well if you
look at this table job titles generally
pretty you know not too sensitive but
we're really looking at here is there's
kind of a distribution of job titles
even in just these five Records we have
for software engineers and we have one
CEO of goo
and it's a very unique one in our
dataset but also anyone who sees that
job title is probably gonna know who
that is and they've now learned what
their metric is if this was if this was
published alongside other data and so
really when we talk about something like
Kanan emit a or some of these we
identify patient Alice's tools we're
trying to look at some of these high
risk outliers identify them and then
figure out how to how to deal with them
and we'll show a little bit more of that
later so when we think of applying these
tools you know we're really thinking of
how do we gain more intelligence about
your sensitive data again maybe you have
a lot of data in a cloud project
applying our API the DLP API to
basically scan that data highlight where
you have sensitive data do some
additional analytics you can write the
findings directly to bigquery and run a
lot of analytics in bigquery or
visualize something like an audit report
in something like data studio and we're
gonna walk through this in the demo and
show you how to build an audit report
the other thing again you'd use is to do
things like 2d identify this data maybe
it's structured data or unstructured
data to go in and apply some sort of
remediation or Risk Reduction great so
now we're going to go and we're gonna
kind of show this in action just as a
reminder though this is what we're gonna
cover we had we have kind of this
scenario we're gonna go through and
we're going to basically create a scan
to try to discover where our sensitive
data exists in our cloud project we're
then going to go through and do a
real-time redaction and kind of apply
how you might remediates some unexpected
collection with that and then dive a
little bit deeper and do in 2d
identification and risk analysis and
show how that can be applied to a in
kind of a practical scenario to a real
data set and again we're going to try to
provide as many of these samples as we
can there's a link at the end kind of a
short link you can look at that we'll
have samples or links to our how-to
guides that already published just so
you can try to recreate some of these
things if you want to great so the first
thing we're going to look at is we're
going to again create a scan to discover
where sensitive data exists in our
project we think this is important to
start with because before you can
properly handle data you have to know
where it is and whether you whether
you're looking at it at the project
level maybe the bucket level or the
dataset level of the table level to set
like access control
or you're looking at it all the way down
at the actual content and the string
level where you're trying to find a
string of text inside of a data set that
you want to redact all that begins with
knowing where it is and so what we're
going to do today is we're going to use
the DLP API to discover data in our
cloud storage we have this bucket that
we've created on the on the right side
that's sort of a company-wide bucket
we've got data from different
departments that's thrown in there
finance legal marketing some production
and research data and our goal is we
want to produce an audit report
basically do a scan of this data print
up what you found where you found it and
see if there's any issues and very
specifically we want to make sure that
we're not storing or writing raw
credit-card numbers anywhere on our
infrastructure and we've also in some of
these folders we've got you know small
files in some cases we've got some big
files in here so this is just a
screenshot of sort of the production
folder where there's kind of a
relatively large csv files being
exported in here so we want to also take
that into consideration both like speed
efficiency and you know cost efficiency
of how we run the scan so what we're
gonna do is we're going to effectively
initiate a scan using our DG cloud
integration with DLP so what G cloud is
is it's a command line interface that
you can use to kind of interact it's a
lot of cloud products whether you're
copying the file or accessing something
and let's say bigquery it's really a
simple command-line interface you can
use it doesn't require coding it just
run a command and see it happen we're
gonna use our DLP integration with that
to accomplish this we're gonna tell that
command to save the findings in bigquery
and then we're going to use data studio
to visualize an audit report and and
show you what that could look like great
so let's switch over to the demo joining
switch over to demo 1 and what we're
going to do here is that we're gonna
initiate that command in G cloud so
we're first just going to open the cloud
shell
and again we're gonna kind of walk
through all the steps here this is
running in cloud shell which is a simple
way to get a command prompt just by
logging into our cloud console you could
obviously run this on your own VM or
your own local machine if you have G
cloud installed and so first what we're
gonna do is we're gonna list out all the
jobs so we're gonna look at a relatively
simple command that just says hey to dlp
go list all the jobs that I have for
this project and as you see we've
created a couple jobs here very simple
jobs looking for a couple things that
we're gonna look for and then we're
gonna actually let's create a new job
and I'll talk through this command for
one second again it's a relatively
simple command line but it's still
pretty powerful what we're specifying
here is we're gonna scan our cloud
storage we put in a what's called a URL
or URI for the cloud storage bucket
we've specified that we want to write
the output to our bigquery table that we
that we manage which is in this case is
in a certain data set and the table's
called results one we said we're gonna
look for a phone number email address
credit card number and something called
GCP credentials which I'll explain in a
little bit what that is
and we're gonna do a very fast limited
scan we didn't want to scan everything
exhaustively we just want to do a kind
of a very fast limit scan so go ahead
and run this command so by issuing this
command it's gonna respond back with a
hey I created a job here's some details
about it so if you go ahead and go back
and do the list jobs command we'll see
now that we should have a third job
showing up there that's currently
running so again it's that simple just
create a command like that and you're
already scanning an entire cloud storage
bucket next we're going to jump over to
data studio we've created a little
relatively simple audit report and what
we've done here with this audit report
is we've basically just created a couple
charts in grass but fundamentally what
we're doing is we're reading from that
bigquery table that are that the DLP
creates it basically takes all that
scanning and the findings and creates a
structured database and then we've just
shown that here so in this left side
here we're showing a kind of a simple
listing of the files and and count of
what was found there on the right side
again we looked for four different types
and we just show a count of the four
different types that we found
phone number and email was the most
prevalent we've got a little bit of a
warning it might be hard to see but that
kind of red pink credit cards up there
is a highlight that we found something
of that particular type and let's go
ahead and drill down we're gonna limit
it to just one of the jobs that we ran
here and then we'll drill down once it
loads and look at just credit cards so
we're limiting it to just one of the
jobs here and what this does is we've
basically said now just show us the
files that have credit card numbers and
we see that we have one file here that
looks like our a copy of our chat
transcripts it looks like there was some
raw credit card numbers in there and so
that's something we're going to
investigate next but before we do that
let's go ahead and jump over and just
look at another type that GCP
credentials so this isn't necessarily a
type of PII or personally identifiable
information what this is is it's a
detector for kind of GCP service
accounts so if you if you create a
service account save it as like a JSON
file to use this looks like somebody
created one of these service accounts
and uploaded it to one of our cloud
storage buckets and that may be of a
concern if a lot of people have access
to that and that has access to your
resources your data that's something you
want to be aware of and so you want to
make sure that that is properly
protected or removed from cloud storage
that's just another example of things
that the API can look for great so I
think let's jump back to the slides and
we walk through the g-cloud command here
and again so what did we look for where
we accomplished our goal we created an
audit report this report looks like we
found several files that have PII one of
which contained raw credit card numbers
which is something we really wanted to
to make sure we didn't have and we also
found what looks like a maybe a
production GCP service account kind of
JSON file now before we move on to the
next step we want to dive a little
deeper into the technical details of
what the API would have looked like so
again we used a g-cloud command but
let's look at what that API call might
have looked like if you were to just do
a direct API call or if you're using a
you know particular client library or a
different language kind of more the
details here so what we're showing here
is a JSON representation of like the the
REST API call
and what we're doing here is if you kind
of remember from the g-cloud command
we're gonna go through what that API
call would kind of look like so first we
would specify where we want to scan in
this case it's a cloud storage bucket
maybe we're gonna put some limits and
sampling on it so pick some settings on
how to do that specify what to look for
I've put a couple different types in
here just to show that different ones we
have but essentially you just put the
name of the type and that's gonna
trigger our detector to run so in this
case credit card number or social
security number and a few others and
then what action you want to take after
the job is done in this case we just
want to write it out write out detailed
findings into bigquery so that's a
simple API call again you could do all
that in the G cloud as well so next
we're going to look at kind of how do we
remediated chat file that we found or
like what caused that how could we
prevent it from happening again I'm
going to try to apply some real-time
redaction to remediate this so if we
dive into one of these chat transcripts
I just put a sample of it here what we
see is that um it looks like there's
information in there that we didn't need
to collect and so we're gonna try to
figure out what that is and how we might
remediated and in some cases you might
call that data minimization kind of a
term of make sure you're only collecting
the minimum amount of data that you need
and in this case it wasn't intended to
collect this information but we
definitely didn't need it and we did
collect it so what we're gonna look at
here is in the chat session as you see
the agent asked for the last four digits
of a social and the customer gave the
full social later on he said something
about a card and it looks like we got a
full credit card number so these are
things we didn't want and we really
don't want the agent to see it in the
first place and we definitely don't want
to save it persist it and have to manage
that data so what we're gonna do is
we're going to feed these chat messages
into our content methods of our API
which is kind of a streaming real-time
method and we're going to de-identify
them by masking or redacting the
information that we don't need and
produce sort of a cleaner chat message
and that's what we're going to show to
the agent and that's what we're going to
persist in our in our system so let's go
ahead and switch over to the demo one
again and we're just going to load an
application here that we've
kind of created to show this and what
we've created here is a simple App
Engine application this particular one's
written and go will send a link to some
of the go code after at the end of the
talk and what we're showing here is on
the left side we've got a box where we
can type things in and then the right
side we're going to show what that would
look like after it's been processed by
our API in real time so let's go ahead
and load the sample chat and what we see
here on the left is as that kind of
information is typed in on the right
side is how we're applying a policy here
and in this case we've decided to apply
a policy that will mask everything but
the last four digits of social security
numbers and fully redact other things
like credit card numbers so something
that's simple again as you're typing we
can apply that policy and you have full
control over what the policy looks like
what you look for and things like that
and good I think let's switch back over
to the slides okay so that's kind of
applying it in real time so you imagine
you can build that directly into your
chat support app feedback app things
like that that might be collecting data
where you don't expect it to have this
certain sensitive data in there and like
we did before let's just dive a little
into the details of what that might look
like on the API side so again we're
going to look at an API call here and in
this case we're not scanning cloud
storage so we didn't give it a like a
bucket to scan but instead we actually
stream the data in so here's an example
of just streaming a string of text in
we've asked it to look for social
security numbers and apply a masking
transform and then for other things like
credit card number just simply redact so
again this is showing a little bit of
what that like transform or D
identification policy might look like or
the D identification config and we
applied this to something that we built
just as a little simple app like App
Engine example but if you think about
it's in a real-time so as you have data
in other systems or you have third-party
data that has API is where you can use
this data you can also build this into
other systems so we've you know played
around in this a little bit and built
like like a in this example we built a
slack bot that we kind of went in and
said hey let's see if we can use the
api's from slack build a simple slack
bot stream that data through our API and
we set up this demo chatroom and we kind
of put some information in there and
then
Manickam and and said what's there so in
this case you can see you can build it
in a third parties you can kind of use
it on data virtually anywhere whether
it's a real-time case like this or data
that you just manage this off TCP or in
some system that you control and next
we're going to dive a little deeper into
D identification and risk analysis and
my colleague here Michael is going to go
and present that for you and here you go
Michael thanks Scott
so my name is Michael DAB I'm a software
engineer working on cloud DLP and so for
the second half of the demo I'm going to
talk about some of the more advanced
features that we offer with the DLP API
specifically D identification and risk
analysis of large structured data so
recall in the last demo Scott showed you
how to identify these chat messages in
real time to make sure the agent doesn't
see it and that we're not persisting it
but you might imagine that we've already
collected these messages and we haven't
performed the identification yet and
we're already storing them in bigquery
and we need to go back and make sure we
eliminate any PII that we don't actually
need alternatively you could imagine a
situation where there is sensitive data
that serves a legitimate business
purpose but some internal team needs
access to the data for analysis but they
don't need access to the sensitive data
and so in either of these cases we need
to take this data that lives in bigquery
de-identified just like in the previous
demo and then write it back to bigquery
so a copy of it can be shared with the
analysts so it's going to look very
similar to what we did before except the
data instead of originating in the chat
app is going to originate in bigquery
then we're going to send it the DLP API
for D identification and then write it
back to bigquery
and do the exact same transformation as
we did before except this time instead
of doing in real time we're gonna do it
in batch and so we're going to use cloud
dataflow to orchestrate the work flow
that what reads the data from bigquery
calls the DLP API and then writes it
back to bigquery and so we're going to
use some open source code that Google
publishes to github again at the end of
the end of the session we'll provide you
with a link to the github project so
that you can run the code on your own
bigquery table if you like and so right
now we're not going to run data flow
live we're going to do that in a moment
so we're just going to skip over to the
results and so if you take a look the
top section is the data before we
actually apply D ID and the bottom is
after and so first I'm going to call
your attention to the user ID field so
in the top before ID before we di
Denton's just this sequential user ID
which is the raw user ID that we don't
want to to share with the analysts
because they might have access some
other data source but then they could
join on this using the user ID column
and so we don't want them to have that
but we might want to at a later time
taking the analysis they've done and
figure out who the person is so instead
of just redacting it we're going to use
format preserving encryption where we're
going to apply cryptography using a
private key that can then be used later
to reverse it and in the output it just
looks like some random number but it's
actually encrypted and can be reversed
and then in the chat messages we're
gonna scan for in this case the the
customer servant a service agent names
as well as social security numbers and
some of the other PII and then just
replace them with the type of pi that
was found so that the analysts will know
what type of pi is missing but not the
actual sensitive contents and so the
technical details it's the exact same
API request that Scott made Scott showed
before I'm just going to highlight some
other call your attention some other
parts of it just like before we are
going to list some built-in system
defined intro types that are available
to everybody
but you can imagine that you can't
expect you wouldn't expect the DLP API
to know about specific types that are
only gonna exist in your data set
because they're specific to your
business
for example the custom case number in
this case is just going to be to
uppercase letters followed by six digits
so using our custom reg X detector you
can actually define your own type and
then for the custom agent name we just
provide a list of of all the customer
service agents that are employed by the
company in a dictionary that lives in a
file in Google Cloud storage and then if
you just provide that the API will look
up the dictionary and then search for
those those custom agent names and in
the data and then in terms of the the
de-identification config so for the user
ID here we've just defined the the
format preserving an encryption with the
provided key to encrypt those user id's
and then redact everything else replace
it with the name of the info type so now
suppose that you're not sharing with an
internal team you actually need to share
it with some external marketing firm to
perform further analysis in this case we
need to take a bit more care because
we're sharing it with a with a team that
might be a little less trusted than an
internal team and so we've already taken
the obvious steps of protecting what are
called direct identifiers things that
will always obviously identify a user
like user ID social security number and
so forth
but since we want to take a bit more
care what else do we have to worry about
so there there's this concept called
quasi identifiers which are identifiers
that may not directly identify somebody
if you recall the example Scott gave
earlier of job title for the most part
job Hetal won't directly identify
somebody but
CEO of Google certainly would in this
case we're actually going to look at zip
code and age which any particular zip
code in any particular age they're
probably going to be multiple people in
your dataset for for a given zip code or
age but now actually quasi identifiers
can be identifying when taken together
unique hominid a specific combination of
zip zip code and age might uniquely
identify a user just because the zip
code might have a low population and the
age might be a demographic with very low
population as well and so in this sample
data set observe that there might be
five people of this zip code and maybe
there are more that we're not showing
but there could be a one person whose
age is 81 and that person would be
highly identifying and so we want to
make sure that we're not sharing this
with the marketing firm because they
might have access to public data sets
that contain these demographic features
or they might have their own internal
data sets and we want to stop them from
from joining any other data sets on this
one or doing any other kind of thing
that would expose the users personal
data so so how do we how do first of all
how do we deal with these outliers and
also how do we measure the risk so one
thing we could do is we could just
remove all these outliers going back to
this previous slide for a sec we could
drop all these unique combinations of
zip code and age but there could be only
two people or three people with a given
set of quazy identifiers and that's
still risky even though they're not
uniquely identifiable so to talk about
this kind of risk we're going to use the
concept of K anonymity which if you're
not familiar with don't worry about it
too much it's quite simple it's just how
many people share the same set of quazy
identifiers agent zip code in our case
in the given data set and so for every
possible combination of agent zip code
we're going to count the number of
people and that's what Canon MD is and
in our case we're going to target a
policy of K equals 10 this could vary
from use case use case depending on who
you're sharing with it and what your
your assumptions and about the attacker
might be and how much risk you can
tolerate but for the purposes of this
demo we're going to aim for K equals 10
and so we're gonna do is we're going to
take the data which lives in bigquery
and we're going to call the DLP API the
risk analysis method to compute K and
enemity then we're going to take the
output
Google data studio to visualize the
results so if we can switch back over to
the demo okay
so as you can see Scott has pulled up
the Google API Explorer which allows you
to make API calls to various Google
cloud services and so here he has a
request up for for the DLP risk analysis
API it's fairly simple so we're just
defining the quasi identifiers we care
about in this case it's agent zip code
and then below we just specify the
source table which is our chats to table
and then again we're going to specify an
action we want to save the results so we
can generate the histogram and we're
going to save it to this table live risk
before R 1 or X 1 and then we're gonna
give it a unique job ID so we can figure
out which job corresponds to the results
and then hit execute and hopefully it
worked yep and so on a larger dataset it
might take longer but this is a test
data set so probably it's probably
already done it only takes seconds so
we're going to switch over to Google
Data studio and open up this report we
made and don't worry about how we
generated this report there's a detailed
how-to guide that we're going to provide
at the end of the talk but for now
before looking to much of the graph
let's talk about what these axes mean
and and and sort of figure out what this
graph means so the x axis which is
labeled K and enemity is just as we
talked about the number of users for
each set of values of quasi identifiers
but in this case we've accurately
aggregated it together into a histogram
so at the far left K equals 1 we've just
taken everybody who lives in a zip code
a particular age that's uniquely
identifying and aggregated them into one
bucket and said the blue line is the
number of rows or the percentage of
total rows that correspond to K equals 1
and the red is the percentage of unique
zip and age combinations and so the
results won't look very good because
just for cables one already ten percent
of the data is K equals one and 27
percent of the values and it quickly
jumps up to the point where once we
reach
cables nine a hundred percent of our
data is lost both in terms of the number
of rows and the number of distinct age
zip code combinations so this isn't good
we can't just by removing all of these
outliers achieve our goal of K equals
ten without losing all of our data and
so can we switch back to the slides so
how do we fix this it seems like we're
an impossible situation because we we
can't remove the risky outliers but we
also need some data to analyze and so
the solution is to use generalization
using the DLP API so generalization is a
technique for instead of just completely
dropping data we're going to replace it
with a value that's not as specific so
for example we might take ages in a
particular range and instead of
outputting the exact age we're going to
output buckets of ages so we might take
all numbers between 20 and 30 and just
output 30 all numbers 30 and 40 and
that's output 40 and so forth and if we
do this it'll reduce the it'll reduce
the granularity of the data and reduce
the risk and so now we're going to do
for this final part of the demo is we're
going to combine the last two steps
where we used data flow to to perform
the identification this time we're gonna
do the exact same thing as we did before
but we're going to add this bucketing
transformation we didn't do the first
time and we're gonna bucket the ages to
make it a little bit a little bit less
identifying then we're gonna perform the
second step take the output pipe it into
DLP's risk analysis API and then once
again see how the results compare to the
to the first de-identified run the the
data that did not have the bucketing
performed and so switch back to the demo
and so now we're gonna actually show the
running of the dataflow pipeline which
Scott's just going to SSH into a virtual
machine which we've installed this
github library on
and the github page has all the
instructions on how to run this so don't
worry too much about the exact command
but this Casas is going to prepare it by
exporting the credentials so that we're
authenticated when we actually call data
flow and so now we're going to run this
command which again don't worry too much
about it but we're we're specifying the
input table chats to we're specifying
the output table which Scott is called
live D ID chats to bucket 10x2 and then
the configuration which we is the same
configuration we used before except it
has the bucketing transformation and so
the the datasets pretty small so when
Scott runs it it should finish probably
within seconds for a larger data set it
might take a bit more time but for this
test data set it's done pretty fast and
so now we're going to switch over to
bigquery real quick just to look at the
output and so first Scott's going to
pull up the the data set chats - which
was the the original data set that is
not yet been de-identified and if we
look at it ages now 18 19 20 21 so forth
have not been bucketed we've just for
the purpose of this demo dropped the
chats but normally we might keep the
chats in there but just for the to make
to speed up the D identification and
data flow we remove that and so now if
we go to the output table it's all the
same columns except now we've applied D
ID and looking at the output now you see
there are no ages except for exact
multiples of 10 because we bucketed them
all together and so now we're going to
quickly go back to the API Explorer and
rerun risk analysis on this output data
set and so Scott's just going to copy
the table name that we we just wrote the
output to and the API request is going
to be exactly the same because we're
running the same metric the only
difference is we want to run it on a
different output table the the newly
de-identified date data set and then
we're going to write it to a slightly
different output table
and we're also going to use a different
job ID because we already used live risk
before x1 we're just going to call it
live risk after x1 and hopefully this
will work
alright good so now if we switch back to
data studio we're going to take the
exact same chart we prepared before but
we're just going to change the data
source to the new table that we wrote
the output of risk analysis to so if
Skott just going to click Edit and then
change the data source from the original
data set to the one we just created and
once that's done the graph will be
updated and we're gonna see what the
results of applying this bucketing was
on the risk so it's disappearing now if
you recall it started out relatively
high and then quickly jumped up in terms
of the amount of data loss experienced
by removing the outliers but this looks
much better already because if you look
at K equals one it's kind of hidden but
it says 0.3 percent only 0.3 percent of
all rows correspond to K equals 1 after
applying this bucketing and only 5
percent of the values are lost if we
wanted k equals 1 and it increases very
slowly up to K equals 8 the data loss
and only starts jumping up once we hit K
equals 15 and we can get actually all
the way up to K equals 40 before we lose
all of our data but since our goal was K
equals 10
this was success we can hit K equals 10
and only lose about 4 percent of the
rows and about 20% of our distinct
values so switch back to the slides
and so I'm just gonna skip over that
because we already started the graph
that was a backup so let's just look at
the technical details real quick we use
the exact same D ID to config we showed
you earlier only we added this extra
bucketing config for applying the
bucketing transformation to the age
column and it's actually a very flexible
API we just say what the min
value in the max value of the range for
the bucketing is and in this case we
define the replacement value to be the
upper end of the range 30 but you could
define it to be whatever you want you
could you could make it a string that is
just 20 - 30 sort of gives a range you
could choose the lower end point 20 the
mid point 25 the upper end 30 or pretty
much whatever you want and so quick
summary of what we just showed you is
first Scott showed you how to scan your
Google Cloud Storage bucket for
sensitive data and generate an audit
report then he showed you how to in
real-time D identify the chat messages
so that analysts didn't have to see PII
and so that we weren't storing that the
the sensitive data we didn't need and
then we showed you in the second half
how to deify a data set using data flow
and share with an internal team and then
use risk analysis to make sure it's safe
for sharing with the next penalty
you
[Music]